[Music]
what's that about Total Recall I got to
see this movie obviously you've been
given a new identity a new memory and
you're starting to come out of that and
you're talking to the woman you believe
is your wife my wife absolutely Kate
Beckett which is actually the director's
wife that's right she's moderate to the
demands of the director who's moderately
uncomfortabie ting her up because you
don't actually beat each other up but
kissing her was a little bit dodgy
because the rector well he wasn't the
drug house wasn't kind enough to leave
the room you know he stayed and but he
had to kind of being a director you have
to watch the scene it's creepy for the
guy who's his wife and she's there and
you two were having quite a passionate
it's a little bit creepy yeah he's there
like do it again yes the one thing the
one thing he didn't say was Colin I
think you just give it more not pull it
back I'm Irish I'm not yes I don't know
where you're going with listen you're
doing your own whole life